In this lecture,
we discuss the idea
of predictive
analytics in medicine.
Specifically, we
introduce the idea
of using clustering methods
for better predicting heart
attacks.
Heart attacks are a common
complication of coronary heart
disease, resulting from the
interruption of blood supply
to part of the heart.
Heat attack is the
number one cause
of death for both men and
women in the United States.
About one in every four
deaths is due to heart attack.
A 2012 report from the
American Heart Association
estimates about 715,000
Americans have a heart attack
every year.
To put this number
into perspective,
this means that every
20 seconds, a person
has a heart attack
in the United States.
It is also equivalent
of September the 11th
repeating itself every 24
hours, 365 days a year.
Nearly half of
these attacks occur
without prior warning signs.
In fact, 250,000 Americans
die of sudden cardiac death
yearly, which means 680
people every day die
of sudden cardiac death.
A heart attack has well-known
symptoms-- chest pain,
shortness of breath,
upper body pain, nausea.
The nature of heart
attacks, however,
makes it hard to predict,
prevent, and even diagnose.
Here are some statistics.
25% of heart attacks are silent.
47% of sudden cardiac deaths
occur outside hospitals,
suggesting that many patients do
not act on early warning signs.
Only 27% percent of
respondents to a 2005 survey
recognized the symptoms
and called 911 for help.
How can analytics help?
The key to helping
patients is to understand
the clinical
characteristics of patients
in whom heart
attacks was missed.
We need to better understand
the patterns in a patient's
diagnostic history that
link to heart attack
and to predicting
whether a patient is
at risk for a heart attack.
We'll see, in this
lecture, how analytics
helps to understand
patterns of heart attacks
and to provide good predictions
that in turn lead to improved
monitoring and taking action
early and effectively.